and the controversial mosque being
planned in the shadow of the World Trade
Center a $100 million project but now
there's suspicions about where all that
money's coming from all that and more on
money
[Applause]
[Music]
rocks hi I'm Eric bowling welcome to
money rocks where we expose crime
corruption arrogance and the shocking
betrayals of public trust cutting down
on public corruption would amount to a
huge huge tax cut for America and save
us all money the mosque being planned
near Ground Zero in New York City
expected to cost $100 million in
questions are being raised about where
that money is going to come from
meanwhile in Washington President Obama
came out in favor of the mosque causing
what could be a big split among
Democrats uh Fox Craig Boswell reports
from Washington
as President Obama begins a new work
week it's his comments over the weekend
that continue to capture attention at a
White House dinner Friday night the
president reiterated the rights of
Muslims to practice religion freely in
the US that includes the right to build
a place of worship in a community center
on private property in lower Manhattan
the president's comments were widely
reported as support for an Islamic
culture center in mosque a couple of
blocks away from the World Trade Center
attacks on Saturday the president
offered a slightly different message I
was not commenting and I will not
comment on the wisdom of making a
decision uh to put a MOS there
Republicans say the president is trying
to have it both ways and the highly
emotional debate is likely to become a
campaign issue I think that's a sign he
got a lot of very angry phone calls from
democratic members of the House and
Senate who uh realize he taken a
position that was not defendable and
that was going to make their re-election
even harder Washington the White House
the administ ation the president himself
seems to be disconnected from the
mainstream of America Democrats disagree
I think the overriding issue Remains the
economy and that that issue will be the
most dominant one as we go forward into
the election after delivering remarks on
the economy today President Obama begins
a three-day fundraising trip for
Democratic candidates from Wisconsin to
California Washington Ohio and Florida
in Washington Craig Boswell Fox News now
there's a question uh also of the money
being used to build the mosque
apparently 100 million of funding is
coming from what some could say are
questionable sources we'll hear from our
All-Star panel in a second but first we
want to follow the mosque money trail
with Pamela Geller who's executive
director of stop islamization of America
and author of the book post American
presidency the Obama administration's
war on America Pamela thanks for joining
us boy this thing has just heated up I
did about three hours of uh radio today
and anytime you mention mosques the
lights just went ballistic they went lit
up like a Christmas tree you can talk
about anything else
go light here and there but everyone
wants to talk about this I want to
follow the money Pamela tell us where
this money is going to come
from well it's deeply disturbing because
we know he's not been honest he has a an
Imam who advocates for tolerance and yet
in his book he advocates for the Sharia
which is radically intolerant um we know
that he is a prominent member in the
Pana organization in Malaysia the Pana
organization was the single largest
Finance year of the terrorist group in
Turkey I H which launched the Jihad the
genocidal flotilla to provoke the tiny
Jewish State into defending itself we
also know that both his organization and
his wife Daisy Khan received money from
xnl xnl is a Saudi Arabian company with
ties to bin laddin and alqaeda
interestingly enough a few years ago a
100 million Convention Center was killed
in kissm Florida because of ties to ex
out well you're talking about Imam R Who
right now I believe is overseas uh
visiting some Muslim countries talking I
guess raising money for the for this
mosque is that accurate to say well
what's so ging is that your taxpayer
dollars are paying for this trip to the
Middle East to all the countries where
the Muslim terrorists came from Saudi
Arabia Qatar Dubai Malaysia yes he's on
a state department trip now PJ Crowley
who looked absolutely clueless when uh
when asked about this says oh he won't
be fundraising but they're making the
contacts for him they're hooking him up
with the biggest money in some of these
countries that have very very
questionable ties to terrorist hang in
there pan hang in there I want to bring
the panel in today's All-Star panel Bill
Hammer host of America's Newsroom on Fox
News Channel CMP group president Tom
Ruskin and Democratic strategist Bob
Becka Bob I'm going to start with you my
friend um I I guess it's still
speculation what he's actually doing uh
visiting all these Muslim countries but
it sure sounds like and feels like this
Imam R is raising money for the for the
ground zero mosque sounds like feels
like yeah and not a bit of evidence that
it's true I just listen to this lady
when you ask her the question where's
the money coming from and there's not a
single dollar she said yet was directed
at a mosque and so I I mean you he may
and the other thing about Iman if you
let me do this what's he doing there
then I assume he's going on a maybe he's
going to ask for money maybe he's not
but you can't make that flat out
assertion I mean if you would to take if
you would to take what you just said
ma'am and what you just said you could
draw the conclusion the United States
government was funding this mosque well
well pamel am I wrong that to say that
the state department I think the state
department is funding this uh IM this
trip to to these Muslim countries if he
does in fact raise money go ahead clear
it up he is Absolut the state department
is absolutely funding this trip and
while he speaks again of Tolerance he he
speaks against the ideology that
inspired Jihad he will not denounce a
genocidal group like Hamas he has no
money what does that have to do what
does that have to do with money you got
you your R here I listen to yourap I
want to hear what you have to say about
money get specific where's the money
coming from yeah I am he he has no he
has no money it's coming it's first he
said there would be no foreign funding
and now he says there will be foreign
funding so the money's coming from
foreign funding
hang it might on you spend you spend a
lot of time talking to people I
interviewed PJ crowler last week on
America's news and Friday morning in
fact the trip has not taken place yet in
fact he wasn't even sure when the trip's
going to happen it will be his third
taxpayer funded trip overseas the first
one happened in 2007 this is a program
that was started under George Bush and
the C mom has taken advantage of it
under American law you cannot go
overseas and raise money under American
law you cannot go overseas and promote
your religion under American law you
cannot prze an American taxpayer dollars
the only way to make sure this does not
happen is to be with him every minute of
every day that he's on a trip overseas
to make
sure say under American law under
American law you're not allowed to cross
the border either the fact of the matter
is these things are happening it's silly
the other the property developer uh
Sharif Al Gamal was a was a waiter two
years ago we're going to have to leave
it there we have a lot to get to we
appreciate your time thank you very much
for joining us we're now going to bring
in uh Ibraham Hooper from the Council on
American Islamic relations sir um if the
Imam goes overseas and raises money for
whatever cause I mean maybe it's not
this mosque is it the same
thing uh well as the other commentator
said that it is against the law to go
and raise money on one of these State
Department sponsored trips but let me uh
get back to your original speaker Miss
Geller uh I mean she's on there she's a
perfect example of what's Happening Here
there's a cottage industry of Muslim
Bashers who are exploiting the
legitimate emotions of 91 what doing
what's what's this Imam doing then if
he's not there to to raise
money uh he's over there building
Goodwill for the United States but I
want to ask Miss
Gill she's gone so we can't do that
anymore she's gone she she didn't have
sheon have you have on a guest who put a
video on her website Muslims have sex
with goats okay listen to me listen do
me a favor let let's keep the
conversation here Mr Hooper if you want
to talk about this Imam and this mosque
will do that but we're not going to take
shots at a guess who already going just
clear up here it's possible that if he
makes if and when he makes this trip
that he could turn it into a taxpayer
funded uh a fundraiser trip well but but
it's not stated that way my point is
that to make sure that doesn't happen
you have to babysit him the entire how
much Tommy what are you going to do you
walk around with him go to Every
cocktail party and whatever else they do
as Bill's alluding to that's ridiculous
you can't be with him every minute but
the people he meets there's nothing
stopping him from later on contacting
and raising money with those people B go
ahead uh just excuse me I got to put an
earpiece in because this show go ahead
Mr go ahead you want to respond to this
it's really Hightech around here I gotta
go ahead Mr Hooper go ahead you Tommy
says we and Bill say we should uh maybe
have someone attached to the mom's hip
can we do that realistically
well again this Imam is known as a
promoter of pluralism tolerance Mutual
understanding and for him to come under
attack from this uh extremist smear
machine is truly bizarre but it shows
that any Muslim who raises their is this
not the gentleman is this not the
gentleman in just weeks after the 9/11
attacks uh the attacks on the World
Trade Center he said uh quote because we
have been um accessors uh to to to a lot
of this was blaming the US for the 9/11
attack he I'm sure he was talking about
American foreign policy as many people
inside outside the Muslim Community
that's a standard issue guy though right
same guy hang on hang on same guy Tommy
you you lost some friends in the World
Trade Center right I
lost either I knew or worked how do you
feel about this many Muslims died in the
World Trade Center this guy blaming the
US and now going ahead and being the
face for this mosque that's going to be
built just 600 ft from the world I think
it flies in the face of people who were
lost at the World Trade Center 200 yards
away two football fields away they're
planning to build this musk I I don't
deny their right to be able to do it I
deny their right or their thought
process in putting it so let me just let
me just say something I I was I don't
want to pull rank here but I was a
deputy assistant Secretary of State I
know a little bit about these trips I've
taken a lot of them myself I've taken
people on could you raise money yeah you
could do a lot of things when you're
over there I still haven't heard you or
that woman who you you don't
nobody said anything about the money yet
where's the you haven't said one dime
they don't have the money B they don't
have the money they've told us they
don't have the money yet they're going
to have to raise and frankly I'm
guessing it's not bill it's not going to
be too hard to raise 100 million bucks I
don't know about that but you need 100
million dollar to build the proposed
Moss is 13 or 15 stories tall they're
about a hundred million shy of that
right now I tell you guys I think this
debate will continue for years let me
ask Mr and frankly in the end I'm not
convinced they're going to be able to
get the Moss done
no idea what could come in this IM is if
Imam R Ru comes back from this trip and
all of a sudden mysteriously has the
funding for the uh Ground Zero mosque is
it safe to say that he went over there
to get the funding for that
mosque are you speaking to me yes yeah
uh you know as I as other people said
probably the funding isn't there right
now and uh you know wherever he gets it
it is going to be scrutinized a 100
times over he's going to be the cleanest
uh fundraising effort ever in the
history of uh you know developing uh
property
CLE hold on guys I got to bring this
this is great stuff I want to keep it
going we've heard the money angle let's
bring in Michael Grim he's running for a
New York congressional seat Michael
you've heard all this what are you
proposing you have a a fairly
interesting proposal here well at a
minimum this is shocking I'm hearing all
the things in different perspectives but
I have a a fairly unique perspective
myself all right as a special agent of
the FBI I look at things a little
differently I was an FBI agent for
almost 11 years and I was a 911 first
responder I was there elbow to Elbow
with our fire department with our NYPD
uh digging through the rubble and taking
out remains uh from this pile so it's a
very sensitive very visceral so what do
you want to do sir what do you propose
we have got to find out where the money
is coming from when the money starts to
flow there has to be congressional
oversight we need to do an investigation
first of all one of the first things you
learned learn as a young FBI agent is to
follow the money that's first and
foremost and that there's no
coincidences this this Imam has sent up
several red flares and if we ignore
those now many of them have been
mentioned uh we would be remiss and we
would not be doing what we need to do Mr
Hooper this Imam says he's he's a
moderate Muslim if I'm not mistaken if
he's a moderate Muslim why wouldn't he
propose to move this mosque two or three
blocks away and make everybody happy
well for one thing it's it's a business
decision uh they have a piece of
property they want to
decision well in in large part it's a
business
decision I don't know that anybody has
what business just tell me what business
I mean I I assume it's a place of
worship right I mean it's a it's uh
developing a property and uh you're
you're not going to ask somebody to take
a loss on their property to move prop to
another property when they have an
existing property unless somebody comes
to them
de hang on go ahead there's two points
I'd like to make here Governor Patterson
who is a Democrat Governor of New York
voluntarily threw himself in The Fray
and says we will help you from the
state's perspective of finding an
alternate site that was denied by the
Imam secondly more importantly the fly
in the ointment here is ultimately if
this thing is built it's the New York
City Police Department that's going to
have to put a fixer there a cop there 24
hours a day to protect this mosque
against any terrorist act against the
MOs like the council sit up front foxy
to protect them Eric from these people
look we all do respect just wait we all
do respect people in New American
Muslims have to give up their rights
because they don't have to give up their
protect them Hey listen I'm on your side
so just give me a break all right this
is not about the first Now list is this
guy running for congress right first
responder I congratulate you for that
but look at some point I know it's
sensitive here in New York and probably
New Jersey but we are going to have to
get over 9/11 we're going to have to get
over it
allow me to do this hang on hang on Mr
Hooper hang on we have a this this broke
a couple minutes before Showtime a
spokesman for Senator Harry Reid said
quote the first amendment protects
freedom of religion Senator Reid
respects that but thinks the mosque
should be built someplace else there you
go sir there's the ranking member
theing like all of those uh those
statements of respect for the
Constitution but they're always followed
with the word but in when it comes to
American Muslims and that's a bit true
you know that that's just that's not
true first of all as someone that has
also put on the uniform as a United
States Marine I marched into battle for
the freedoms that this country stands
for okay as a marine I helped to protect
Saudi Arabia and I helped to liberate
Kuwait so there's no question that I
would give my life for the freedoms that
this this this country believes in and
stands for is not about right about
right the
story the story exploded on Friday night
because the White House made a decision
to get to make a statement it continued
on Saturday with this quote unquote
clarification it continues today because
Harry Reed splitting with the white
house I mean this is a story that keeps
going and going and and and frankly the
more people weigh in on it the more fuel
and oxygen it gives the story we're in
mid AUST now
not guys I got to say thank you we're up
against the break we appreciate both of
your time Michael Grim and Ibraham
Hooper you'll join us again if you don't
mind